You know what's a lot harder
than it seems like it should be?
Actually feeling alive.
And what I mean by that
is that we are all constantly doing,
or, at least, we're constantly scrolling.
But we're not necessarily living.
You know, we keep ourselves busy
to the point of exhaustion,
but we're also languishing.
We feel a little bid dead inside.
And I think we know that, on some level.
I think that's part of the reason
we keep ourselves so busy
and distracted to begin with.
But we don't know what to do about it.
So I'm here to tell you
I figured out what to do about it.
We need to have more fun.
(Laughter)
(Cheers and applause)
So you might think that you're already
having plenty of fun,
and that's because in our everyday speech,
we often use the word "fun" to describe
anything we do with our leisure time,
even if it's not actually enjoyable,
and, in fact, a waste of time.
So for example, we scroll
through social media "for fun,"
even though doing so often makes us feel
bad about, like, kind of everything.
Or we'll say, "That was so fun.
We should do that again soon" --
(Laughter)
... in response to things
that weren't that fun
and that we don't want to do again, ever.
(Laughter)
But it's not really our fault
that we're a little bit sloppy
about how we use the word "fun,"
because even the dictionary
doesn't get it quite right.
It says that fun
is amusement or enjoyment,
or lighthearted pleasure.
It's something for kids
to have in play areas.
It makes it sound
like it's frivolous and optional.
But if you think back on your own memories
that stand out to you
as having truly been fun --
and I really encourage you to do this --
the memories that you would describe as --
and forgive me
for scientific terminology --
"so fun" --
you're going to notice
there's something much deeper going on.
I've collected thousands of these stories
from people all around the world,
and I can tell you it's amazing,
because when people recount the memories
in which they had the most fun,
they tell you about some
of the most joyful and treasured
memories of their lives.
So in reality, fun is not
just lighthearted pleasure.
It's not just for kids,
and it is definitely not frivolous.
Instead, fun is the secret
to feeling alive.
So today, I want to propose to you
a new, more precise definition
of what fun is.
I want to reveal some of the ways
in which it is astonishingly good for us,
and I want to give you all
some suggestions
for things you can do starting right now
to experience its power for yourself.
So the first thing we need to start with
is the fact that fun is a feeling,
and it's not an activity.
And that's important,
because a lot of times,
when I ask people what's fun,
they'll respond with a list
of activities that they enjoy.
You know, they'll say, "Dancing is fun,"
or "Skiing is fun," or, I don't know,
"Pickleball is fun."
Everyone seems to think
that pickleball is fun.
(Cheers and laughter)
And sure, pickleball can be fun,
but we've all had experiences
where something's off,
and an activity that seems
like it would be fun
doesn't end up feeling fun.
And then on the flip side,
we've had experiences where something
that doesn't seem like it'll be fun at all
ends up feeling ridiculously fun.
There's an element of serendipity.
But when people do have fun,
when they experience this feeling,
it's actually very easy to recognize,
because people who are having fun
look like they're being
illuminated from within.
So, for example,
here is me and my husband
having fun together.
Here are some presidents
(Laughter)
Here’s Archbishop Desmond Tutu
and the Dalai Lama having fun together.
(Cheers and laughter)
Actually, those two seemed like
they were very often, even constantly ...
(Laughter)
... having fun together.
And as you can see in these photographs,
true fun produces this visceral sense
of lightness and joy.
It's radiant.
In fact, when I asked my daughter,
when she was about five years old,
what color fun would be,
she said "sunshine."
So what is this sunshine?
You know? What is this feeling
that we call "fun"?
When people tell me
their stories about fun,
it's really interesting,
because the details are all different,
and often quite mundane,
but the energy running
through them is the same.
There were three factors
that are consistently present,
to the point that I believe
they constitute a new definition,
one that is a lot more accurate
than what's in the dictionary.
And those three factors
are playfulness, connection and flow.
So by playfulness,
I do not mean you have to play games,
or, God forbid, make believe.
I just mean having a lighthearted attitude
of doing things
for the sake of doing them
and not caring too much about the outcome.
Letting go of perfectionism.
When we have fun, our guard is down,
and we're not taking ourselves
too seriously.
Connection refers to the feeling of having
a special, shared experience.
And I do think it's possible,
in some circumstances,
to have fun alone,
and for this feeling of connection
to be with yourself or the surroundings,
or the activity.
But in the majority of stories
that people tell me
about their peak fun memories,
another person is involved.
And that's true even for introverts.
And then flow is the state
where we are so engaged and focused
on whatever we're doing
that we can even lose track of time.
You can think about an athlete
in the middle of a game,
or a musician playing a piece of music.
It's when we're in the zone.
It's possible to be in flow
and not have fun,
like if you're arguing,
but you cannot have fun
if you're not in flow.
So playfulness, connection and flow
all feel great on their own.
But when we experience all three at once,
something magical happens.
We have fun.
And that doesn't just feel good,
it is good for us.
In fact, fun does so many
amazingly good things for us
that I personally believe that fun is not
just the result of human thriving,
it's a cause.
So, for example, fun is energizing.
When people tell me their stories
about fun, they glow.
It is like a fire has been lit
inside of them,
and the energy and the warmth
that they give off is contagious.
You know, so much of life drains us,
but fun fills us up.
Fun also makes us present.
A lot of us put a lot of work
into trying to be more present --
we do yoga classes, we meditate,
and that is all great,
but the fact that fun is a flow state
means that when we are having fun,
we simply are present.
There's no other way for it to happen.
Fun also unites us.
We live in a really polarized world,
and as we all know,
there's a lot of very serious problems.
But when we have fun with people,
we don't see them
as different political parties,
or nationalities or religions.
We connect with them as human beings,
and it's worth noting
that that is the first step
in being able to work together
to solve those problems.
Fun also makes us healthier.
Being lonely and stressed out,
as many of us have been
for the past two years,
causes hormonal changes in our bodies
that increase our risks for disease.
But when we have fun,
we're relaxed and we're more
socially connected,
both of which have the opposite effect.
So, kind of blows my mind every time
I think about it this way,
but having fun is a health intervention.
And then, lastly, fun is joyful.
You know, we all so desperately
want to be happy.
We read books about happiness,
we download apps about happiness,
but when we are in a moment
of having fun, we are happy.
So it makes me think that, perhaps,
the secret to long-term happiness
is just to have more
everyday moments of fun.
So how do we do that?
How do we have more fun?
Well, to start with,
do not take the suggestions
you'll find in magazine articles
about how to have more fun.
I looked at some of these myself,
and I found suggestions that include --
and I'm not making these up --
"roast a turkey."
(Laughter)
"Put together an altar
to loved ones who have passed."
(Laughter)
“Watch a documentary
about climate change.”
(Laughter)
And my personal favorite,
"Adorn your table with gourds."
(Laughter)
Those are not good suggestions.
Instead, the most effective thing
you can do to have more fun
is to focus on its ingredients,
by which I mean,
do everything you can to fill your life
with more moments of playfulness,
connection and flow.
So here are some ideas for how to do so.
To start with, reduce distractions
in order to increase flow.
Anything that distracts you
is going to kick you out of flow
and prevent you from having fun.
And what's the number one
source of distraction
for most of us, these days?
Oh, thank you.
(Laughs)
It was rhetorical, but yes, your phones.
I wrote a book called
"How to Break Up With Your Phone,"
so I have strong feelings about this,
but I can guarantee you
that you are not going to have fun
if you're constantly on your phone.
So today, I want to challenge you
to keep your phone out of your hand
as much as possible,
so you can take me up
on my second suggestion,
which is to increase connection
by interacting more
with other human beings in real life.
Now, I know that one of the main reasons
we're constantly on our phones
is specifically to avoid
having to spend time
and interact with other
human beings in real life.
(Laughter)
So I want to assure you
that it is worth it,
and it is not as hard as it might seem.
So here's how you do it.
You start by making
eye contact with someone.
Like, look them in the eye,
don't look in the middle
of their forehead,
where the camera would be on a Zoom call.
(Laughter)
And you say “Hello.”
And if that goes well,
you can introduce yourself.
maybe you can ask them a question,
something that's thought-provoking,
but not overly personal or threatening,
like "What's something
that fascinates you?"
Or "What's one thing
that delighted you today?"
And you might be amazed by how good
just one little moment of connection
can make you feel.
And if you do find someone
to connect with,
maybe ask them to join you
in trying my third suggestion,
which is to increase playfulness
by finding opportunities to rebel.
Now I am not talking about
James Dean-level of rebellion.
I'm talking about playful deviance.
I'm talking about finding ways
to break the rules
of responsible adulthood,
and giving yourself permission
to get a kick out of your own life.
One person told me
that some of the most fun
she'd had in recent memory,
happened on a Friday morning,
when she and some of her friends
ditched their work
and their childcare responsibilities,
tucked flasks into their purses
and snuck out to a 10:30am showing
of the movie "Bad Moms."
(Laughter)
So lastly, here's one more thing
that you can do today
to start having more fun.
[Roast a Turkey]
I am just kidding.
(Laughter)
Prioritize it.
That might sound totally obvious,
but one of the main reasons
we're not having enough fun
is that we're not making it a priority.
Our fun is always
at the bottom of the list,
and it can't speak up for itself.
So I'm not suggesting that you take out
your calendar and make an entry
that says: “From 4 to 6pm
on Saturday, I shall have fun.”
That is a guaranteed way to not have fun.
But if you know you consistently have fun
when you spend time
with a particular person,
make a point to spend time
with that person.
If you know there's an activity
that really does often generate
playful connected flow for you,
carve out time for it in your schedule.
Treat fun as if it is important.
Because it is.
I've been doing this myself
for a couple of years now,
and it's amazing to see how many areas
of my life fun has touched.
I'm more creative and more productive,
I'm more resilient.
I laugh more.
Making sure that I'm having enough fun
has made me a better partner,
a better parent and a better friend.
And it has convinced me of something
that I very much hope
I can convince you of as well,
which is that my daughter was right.
Fun is sunshine.
It's a distillation of life's energy.
And the more often we experience it,
the more we will feel
like we're actually alive.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)